Curtis PR is an American inventor he has
almost 200 patents helped design the
first graphics processor ever for PCS in
the early 1980s and later co-founded
semiconductor firm Nvidia where he spent
a decade working as its first Chief
technology officer PR would be the 17th
richest person in America worth about 70
billion had he held on to all of his
Nvidia stock instead he sold out by 2006
and gave most of his fortune to his Alma
moer rener Polytechnic Institute over
the last two decades
Forbes estimates that P now has a
Fortune worth closer to 30 million just
over 1et of what he's given to
RPI that fortune includes a $6 million
home near Fremont California where he
lives off the grid with unreliable cell
service and writes what he calls
manifestos filled with equations about
how to solve world problems like
repairing the Earth since 2001 PR who's
64 and graduated from RPI in 1982 has
given 275 million to The Institute
accounting for 40% of its total gifts
during that period and he's pledged
approximately 80 million more only half
that amount has ever been publicly
acknowledged as gifts from PR an
anonymous pledge of 360 million was
announced by RPI in 2001 around the time
PR started giving but neither he nor the
school would comment on whether he was
the donor 40 million of PR's donation
was used to help construct the
1,165 seat rent poly Technic Institute
Concert Hall which beam calls the most
technically Advanced performance space
in the world the hall is housed in the
Curtis PR experimental media and
Performing Arts
Center but impeccable Acoustics aren't
PR's biggest commitment to his Alma moer
most recently he has helped RPI become
the first University in the world to
house a quantum computer a still rare
very expensive and very fast computer
that relies on quantum mechanical
effects
expected to be operational by Spring of
2024 it will be the Cornerstone of a new
computational center that will hopefully
help RPI and the surrounding area the
capital region of New York attract top
talent the idea for his biggest
contribution yet came in March of 2023
at a board retreat in carlbad
California that's where PR suggested to
rpi's new president Martin Schmidt that
they try to bring a quantum computer to
RPI an interesting idea but one Schmidt
thought would be way too costly among
other
barriers Schmidt told Forbes that the
board left Carl's Bad with him agreeing
that he would drive down to see Dario
Gil the head of IBM research to see if
they could convince him that IPM should
put a quantum computer on the RPI campus
their pitch worked just 3 months later
in June RPI formally announced plans to
build an IBM Quantum system one computer
on campus in in 2024 which would make it
the only University in the world to
house
one at an October groundbreaking event
for the pr funded quantum computer IBM's
head of research said that with quantum
computers RPI would be at the Forefront
of ushering in a completely new paradigm
of computing that offers profound
possibilities for the exploration of a
range of previously intractable problems
across areas such as material design
sustainability pharmaceutical
development healthc care and much more
at that same event PR announced that the
computer would be his last big gift and
began the windown of his family
Foundation